in Black Panther wakanda forever the
talocaniel proved themselves to be not
only skilled fighters in the ocean but
also exceptional fighters on land even
though they can't breathe air this has
made especially clear during okoye's
fears basil with atuma on the bridge in
Boston generally speaking the door
milage wiped the floor with all kinds of
adversaries including super soldiers
however artuma's victory over Okoye in
their first fight is shockingly decisive
although she beats him in a rematch at
salokan's incredible skill is still
firmly established Neymar's fighting
abilities can be choked up to a status
as an amphibious mutant but that isn't
the case with his blue-skinned people so
how did they become such good fighters
on dry land this is a people who have
managed to stay hidden from the surface
world for centuries why are they so well
prepared to take land dwellers on if for
Generations there's been no need to do
so the end of black panther akanda
forever and players will be seeing a lot
more of Namor and his people than the
MCU maybe them will learn how these
underwater people got so good at
fighting in the open air